البدايه من السكر ما قام به صاحب السمو
الشيخ خليفه بن زايد ال نهيان رحمه الله
من اعمال جليله لدوله الامارات العربيه
المتحده الشقيقه والجهود الخير في تعذيب
مسيره عمل المجلس ونسال الله عز وجل لها
الرحمه والمغفره و لصاحب السمو الاخ الشيخ
محمد بن زايد ال نهيان رئيس دوله الامارات
العربيه المتحده التوفيق والسداد كما نهني
اخانا صاحب السمو الشيخ تميم بن حمد
الثاني امير دوله قطر الشقيقه بمناسبه
بمناسبه نجاح متميز في استضافه بطوله كاس
العالم 20 22 اصحاب الجلاله والسمو اقرؤوا
مجلسكم الموقر في دوره 36 في عام 2015
رؤيه خادم الحرمين الشريفين بشيء تعزيز
العمل خليجي المشترك وقد اسهمت الرؤيه في
تعزيز الدور المستطيل الى مجلس التعاون
الاقليميا وعالميا وتسريع وتيره همم وتيره
مسيره المجلس في المجالات الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه والامنيه والعسكريه والسياسيه
بما في ذلك تعيين القيادات العسكريه
القياده العسكريه الموحده وتفعيل دور
الشرطه الخليجيه وفي ضوء تطورات المهمه
خلال السنوات السبع الماضيه التي نزلت عن
تنفيذ الرؤى التنمويه الطموحه التي تبناها
دول مجلس التعاون وخططت تحول الاقتصادي في
المملكه تعتزم تقديم مرحله ثانيه من رؤيا
الخال ما همشري فين بما يعكس تركه تطورات
وياخذ بعين الاعتبار مستجدات الجيوش
سياسيه التي تاثرت بها المنطقه فضلا عن
الدروس المستفاده من التجارب في مواجهه
كورونا والدور المتنامي مجلس مجلس منظومه
مجلس التعاون في قضاء القضايا الاقليميه
والدوليه والنمو الاقتصادي المتسارع
والتنميه الاجتماعيه والثقافيه التي تمر
بها دولنا وما يطلبه كل ذلك من تطور مستمر
والقدرات في التغيير المنظومه الاستعاون
في جميع المجالات نحن على الثقه ان نتعاون
والثيق بيننا سيؤدي الى سرعه تحقيق
الاهداف المنشوده
اصحاب الجلاله والسموم ونؤكد تاكد وان
ضروره وجود حل عادي ودائما قضيه فلسطينيه
وقارات شرعيه الدوليه مبادره السلام
العربيه بما يكفل الشعب الفلسطيني حقا في
اقامه الدوله المستقله على حدود 67
وعاصمتها القدس الشرقيه وتؤكد المملكه
دعمها الكامل للجهود الامويين راميه
للوصول الى حل سياسي شامل الازمه اليمنيه
ماشيه مع عباده المملكه لانهاء هذه الازمه
وفقا للمرجعيات الثلاثه كما تؤكد المملكه
الدوليه والوفاء الالتزاماتها النوويه
والتعاون مع وكاله الدوليه الطاقه الذريه
والمحافظه على مبدا حسن الجوار اصحاب
الجلاله والسمو تؤمن المملكه مصادر الطاقه
الهيدروكربونيه ستظل الامور المهمه لتربيه
الحاجات العالم لعقود القادمه وادراكه منا
لاهميه التنميه المستدامه والحفاظ على
البيئه وانطلاق والمسؤوليتنا تجاه العالم
والرجال القادمه واصل العمل مشترك في
مواجهه التغير المناخي والسائل جاد للحد
من الاثاره ومعالجتها وفي هذا المج قامت
المملكه باتخاذ عديد من الاجراءات حيث
اطلقت المبادره السعوديه الخضره ومبادر
الشرق الاوسط الاخضر مفهوم الاقتصاد
الدائري للكربون والعديد من مبادرات
الهادفه للتنميه التنميه المصادر الطاقه
المستدامه وستظل دول مجلس باذن الله مصدر
الامن وموث به لتزويد العالم بما يحتاجه
من الطاقه واصحاب الجلاله والسمو في ختام
في ختام تراس المملكه للدوره الثانيه
والاربعون لمجلسنا الموقر مهني اخانا
جلاله السلطان هيثم بن طارق ال سعيد على
تولي سلطنه همم تولي سلطنه عمان الرئاسه
الدوره الثالثه والاربعون المجلس الاعلى
متمنيين لجلاله التوفيق والسداد ونؤكد
الدعم المملكه المستمر لرئاسه ولمجلس
التعاون الخليجي والامانه العامه ودعم كل
من شجره ترسيخ الامل خليجي مشترك نسال
الموضوع عز وجل يسدد كل جهودنا بالتوفيق
والنجاح والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
[تصفيق]